When defining your market segment,
you want to make sure you don't
define segments that are too narrow.
Ask yourself, is my offering really
different from one segment to another?
Could be different by price or
by features.
And if you realize that you offer
the same to two different segments,
maybe you should define
them as one bigger segment.
For startups,
it's crucial to measure not only
the quantity of the potential segment,
but its quality.
A quality segment will
help engage users quickly.
Learn from them and
iterate over your products.
Make sure you choose a segment that is
accessible for you, your university,
your group of friends,
or your neighborhood.
If relevant, choose a segment
with the shortest sales cycle, so
you don't wait too long between the time
your customer is exposed to the product
until you can show value.
You could do that by choosing the
segment that will consume a more simple
product, or the segment that will
be willing to pay maybe less but
buy your product more quickly.
If you have a bit of a product, you
better start with the smaller companies
as your customers and
reach out directly to the decision maker
rather than going through a lengthy
process of a big company.
In addition, try to find
a segment that is less crowded, so
you have no or few competitors.
For example, the messaging company
Slack found great opportunity in
the enterprise segment,
with very little competition.
They realized their value was to
focus specifically on tech teams and
small companies and
start-ups that work quickly and
needed to communicate quickly.
With tech features
integrated in their product.
Had they wanted to focus on consumers
rather than enterprise, they would have
been faced with a great deal of good
competition like Whatsapp and WeChat